moi j'ai ma retraite d'être soignante je
peux faire avec
oui c'est ce que c'est je n'ai pas
participé directement
j'ai fait attention à ce qui se passait
j'ai été ravi que ça existe vraiment
ravi parce que c'est quand même une
façon de s'exprimer de simples quoi sans
violence au point de départ et surtout
avec un souci de construire quelque
chose
alors ça vraiment ça m'a touché et quand
je l'entends parler encore du grand
débat dans toute la france ça me touche
encore plus de savoir qui va être
exploité
je l'espère de tout mon coeur tellement
de choses qui nous échappent
1 quand dans ne serait ce qu'avec les
nouvelles technologies ne serait ce
qu'avec nos budget aussi sont limitées
m'enfin moi j'ai pas la prétention non
plus de vouloir gagner gagner à tout
prix une fois que je vis je trouve que
c'est pas si mal quoi et on s'en tire de
sécurité je trouve qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup de sécurité ambiante
c'est à dire j'habite une propriété de
250 logements
je peux vous assurer qu un jour on va
peut-être voir un mur tour tellement les
gens sont agressés tous les uns envers
les autres par des mots par des choses
comme ça et ça me c'est ce qui me
dérange le plus noir
l'autre jour je me disais bien nous
avons commencé à un autre âge école
maternelle publique le très sympa
recommandé avant 6 ans on a beaucoup
apprécié battre vivre ensemble quoi
pourquoi pas on a commencé comme ça et
là je me dis pour les personnages et je
trouve que des foyers logements à leur
portée
comme palier avant d'arriver
complètement à tulle
ça pourrait être plus agréable que voilà